[موسيقى]
الالتزام الامريكي تجاه منطقه الشرق
الاوسط وامن هذه المنطقه تحديدا كان واحدا
من اهم اولويات السياسه الخارجيه لوشنطن
لكن منذ سنوات تراجع هذا الاهتمام بما وصف
بالانسحاب الامريكي من المنطقه فضل
التحديات اخرى بات تعتبرها الولايات
المتحده في الوقت الحالي تشكل تهديدا
وجوديا عليها مثل روسيا والصين
القياده المركزيه الامريكيه هي واحده من
اهم القيادات داخل وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
تعتبر بشكل كبير هي يد واشنطن الضاربه
احيانا وكذلك الراضي احيانا اخرى دورها
العمليات لا يقتصر فقط على منطقه الشرق
الاوسط بل يمتد كذلك الى همم شمال افريقيا
وايضا الى اسيا الوسطى ومناطق اخرى واجزاء
من جنوب اسيا حول الدور العمليات للقياده
المركزيه الامريكيه وكذلك دورها في مساعده
حلفاء واشنطن في هذه المنطقه في التصدي
للتهديدات التي تجابها دول وفي الوقت
الحالي معنا الميجر الجنرال ديفيد هارس
وهو نائب همم قائد القوات الجويه بالقياده
المركزيه الامريكيه اولا جنرال ديفيد اهلا
بك معنا في عسكريتاريا جنرال ديفيد يعني
في ظل التهديدات الحاليه المتسارعه في
منطقه الشرق الاوسط ما هو تقييمكم في
القضيه القياده المركزيه الامريكيه لحجم
هذه المخاطر وكيف تساعدون حلفاء الولايات
المتحده على التصدي لهذه التهديدات ممكن
شكرا انا سعيد جدا للمشاركه في هذه الحلقه
من برنامجكم زياره الاولى للمنطقه كانت
عند افاده الى هنا في عام 2008 وقد تغيرت
التهديدات بشكل كبير منذ ذلك الوقت لقد
شاهدنا تحولا فيما يخص داعش واحتوائه نوعا
لكن مع ذلك فان تهديدات اليوم ليست نفس
التهديدات التي شاهدناها انا ذاك
التهديدات تتطور وتتغير وبدورنا نبحث بشكل
مستمر عن اساليب جديده دعم شركائنا في
التحالف والعمل معهم على شكل فريق المشترك
ما اراه الان هو احتواء داعش بشكل اكبر
كما ارى تنامي التهديدات في مناطق اخرى
ومع اصول المنظومات الجويه غير الماهوله
الى سوريا والعراق اضافه الى تهديدات
الصواريخ البالستيه التي ناخذها على محمل
الجد كل هذا يدفعنا لدعم شركائنا في
المنطقه الولايات المتحده مجرد قطعه صغيره
في هذا التحالف ولابد ان يكون هناك تحالف
في المنطقه من اجل بناء دفاعا صاروخيا
اقليمي متكامل نفس الشيء ينطبق على مكافحه
المنظومات الجويه غير الماهوله وما نستطيع
ان نقدمه الشبكه متكامله لجمع كل الدول
بانظمه مشتركه والمزيد من وعي فضائل لكي
يتمكن من التعرف ليس فقط على تهديدات
الصواريخ البالستيه بل والمسيرات ايضا
التي نرى انها تهديد متنام في المنطقه
بقى انه الولايات المتحده باتت مشغوله
بشكل اكبر سواء بالصين او بروسيا ولم تعد
تعطي منطقه الشرق الاوسط الاولويه كما
كانت تعطي في السابقه هل تتفق مع هذه
الرؤيه
سؤالك هو هل لا تزال هذه المنطقه مهمه
بالنسبه الينا هناك مقوله مفادها قد لا
تكون مهتما بالشرق الاوسط ولكن الشرق
الاوسط مهتم بك وبينما انظروا الى ذلك ارى
اننا بلا شك لدينا الاسباب للوجود هنا فهي
شراكه استمرت منذ امد بعيد ونحن مستمرون
في اجراء الكثير من التدريبات المشتركه
وكل ما زادت هذه التدريبات زادت قدراتنا
وزاد الاثار الراجع لكل التهديدات التي
ذكرناها قبل قليل فاذا ما نظرنا الى
اوكرانيا والصين وبعض التهديدات الاخرى
فقد تعلمنا الدروس من اوكرانيا والدرس
الاول هو ان الجاهزيته هي الاولويه من
وجهه نظري ومعنى ذلك هو انه عن تطور هذه
التهديدات فان الشرق الاوسط باكملها وكل
دول الخليج يجب ان تكون مستعده ومارينه
وقادره على الاستجابه عند الحاجه هذا
النوع من التكامل يتطلب بعض الوقت ونحن
هنا على المدى البعيد لتقديم المساعده
القياده المركزيه تولت مؤخرا من مسؤوليه
تنسيق العلاقات مع الجيش الاسرائيلي
وعلنتم انكم تسعون الى تعزيز العلاقات ما
بين اسرائيل والتعاون ما بين اسرائيل وما
بين حلفاء واشنطن في هذه المنطقه اولا ما
الذي تطمحون اليه في هذه المساله تحديدا
اسرائيل جزء جديد من المنطقه بالنسبه
الينا واعتقد ان هناك اشياء عديده نعمل
عليها مع اسرائيل لدمجهم ضمن التحالف
بالاسلوب الذي تدربنا عليه في الماضي
فاعتقد اننا نحاول ان نؤسس معيار معين
ولكن الشيء الاهم هو اننا قمنا بتعيين
الفريق جرينكو بيتش لقياده القوات الجويه
الامريكيه في القياده المركزيه اعتقد ان
زياراته الحاليه تؤسس تلك العلاقه وبناء
الوفاق مع الاسرائيليين واطراف اخرى لقد
زار الاردن والمملكه العربيه السعوديه
والبحرين فهو مستمر في زيارته لدول
المنطقه لتطوير تلك العلاقات ولكنه ليس
غريبا على المنطقه فقد جاء الى هنا بمنصب
قائد العمليات من القياده المركزيه ولذلك
فقط سبق ان تواصل مع بعض من المنطقه
الجزئيه الخاصه باسرائيل مثيره لاننا نود
التعرف على قدراتهم قات القوه التي يمكن
ان يقدموها لدول الخليج للتعرف على
التهديدات وامكانيه اندماجهم بالشكل
الامثل فريق من قياده القوات الجويه
بالقياده المركزيه الامريكيه قام بزياره
اسرائيل مؤخرا ما الذي كنتم تسعون اليه من
خلال هذه الزياره وهل كان هناك فقط معينه
خلال هذه الزياره الى اسرائيل
سعيد زرتها مؤخرا للمشاركه في مؤتمر
الابتكار من الاشياء التي نبحث عنها في ما
يخص تهديدات المختلفه هي المنظومات الجويه
غير الماهوله فهي رخيصه الثمن وسهله الصنع
ويصعب الدفاع للضحى فهذه الروح الابتكاريه
التي يمكن لدول اخرى ان تقدمها اضافه الى
نظرتهم للمشكلات وتاثيرها مفيد جدا
بالنسبه الينا قد تكون لديهم بعض نقاط
القوه او القدرات التي يمكن ان يقدمها
لدول المنطقه فزيارته لاسرائيل كانت لحضور
مؤتمر الابتكار الذي عقد في منتدى رائعا
بمشاركه العديد من الدول
والكثير من القاده حول العالم يراقبون هذه
الحرب بالنسبه لكم انهم في القياده
المركزي الامريكيه كيف تراقبنا هذه الحرب
وما هي الدروس الاستراتيجيه الاهم
والعسكريه التي تابعتموها من خلال هذه
الحرب وكذلك اداء القوات الجويه سو القوات
الروسيه القوات الجويه الروسيه او حتى
القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه
كما ذكرت مسبقا هناك الكثير من الدروس
التي يمكن ان نستفيد منها من الحرب في
اوكرانيا اول ما يخطر على بالي هو ضروره
الاستعداد فقد اندلعت الحرب بسرعه كبيره
على الرغم من بعض التحذيرات لذلك فان
الجاهليه هي العامل الاهم الذي بوسعنا
تحقيقه عبر التدريبات المشتركه والتكامل
وبناء الشراكه بناء الشراكه او التحالف في
اللحظات الاخيره غالبا ما يتطلب الوقت
وتطوير العلاقات وعوامل اخرى وهذا ما تقوم
به اوكرانيا حاليا فهي تقوم بتشكيل تحالف
الدول ذات الاراده بخلاف هذه المنطقه التي
اسست التحالفات والشركات العظيمه
الامريكيه شكرا جزيلا على هذه التوضيحات